[Music] Up
until now, I had decided that it would be impossible to bridge the gap in my natural talent, and I had
run away from making any effort, but when I
came to Seel Academy and met her, that day I decided that I wanted to
win against Prince Shio.  For the first time, I thought to myself, ``The princess
believed in me like this and wished me victory.'' I
can't afford to lose. That's
a little jealous of me. Oh, my
God, Ame-sama, I'm
getting wet. Hurry and
go somewhere with a roof.  I don't mind this much rain,
but I have to
watch this game to the end,
so I'll
grab an umbrella.  Are you trying to make it worse? Why are you
missing out on Prince Abel making Zion old? This is the reality.
Indeed, this is the essence of imperial Britain, never allowing the talent that lies within every human being to go
unutilized.
[Music] I
see, you're
finally serious. I've been serious for a long time. Your slashing attacks are really
important, which is why I'm advising you, but
if you do the same attack again, you'll lose, right?
In that case, I want to win against you.  There's only one thing to do.If I
change my tactics now, I'm
sure to lose.If the same attack as before won't work, then I'll just have to launch an
attack that surpasses what I've been using before.If that's the case, then I'll
have to attack as well.  Abe
is a rival to whom we should fight with all our might, so we are determined to do so right now.The
tournament has been
canceled.Is that what happened after all?
Fencing tournaments are meant to deepen friendships among students,
so this rain is no good for
this match.  I want to settle the matter someday.Prince
Abel, will you promise me a rematch?
Shion,
Houshi is what I want
[Music]
EN